one of the most incredible biological
adaptations ever discovered in mammals
is one that might be right next to you
or maybe in your bed or on your couch or
on top of comfy mountain
it's one that might even get on your
nerves as your dog yanks your arm off to
smell a light post or guides him to
hoover every ghost of a crumb you may
have ever dropped in your kitchen
a dog's sense of smell is estimated to
be ten thousand to one hundred thousand
times better than our own
this means that dogs can detect some
odors in parts per trillion
to put this into a simple analogy of
taste we humans can detect if our coffee
has a teaspoon of sugar added to it a
dog could detect a teaspoon of sugar in
a million gallons of water or two
olympic-sized swimming pools worth
it's impossible to even imagine what the
experience of smell is like for a dog
when we notice a smell it's because
something is particularly good or
particularly bad we may notice the smell
of freshly baked bread in the air or the
potent dumpster we're walking by but if
you take a smell survey right now you
would likely report that you don't
really smell anything that your
environment is odorless but that
couldn't be farther from the truth
every place object animal and person in
this world is constantly giving off an
explosion of odor and to a dog these
odors convey a suite of rich layered and
complex information
dogs don't experience a sidewalk as
simply a sidewalk to them it's the smell
of concrete of all the foliage nearby of
decaying acorns and the dead frog up
ahead it's the smell of every recent
footfall of every other dog's recent
visit and complex scent trails of the
direction that they went
and time is in those details a dog can
tell when another dog marked that light
post how recently someone walked by with
a bag of treats and how far along in the
decaying process that frog is
but a dog's smelling abilities go so
much beyond snack detecting it's an
ability that could one day save your
life
dogs are employed to track missing
people through the woods
find people buried under feet of snow
and detect dangerous explosives and now
dogs are even being used to detect human
disease
sometimes diseases that should be
undetectable
diseases that we have never figured out
how to spot ourselves until it's too
late how do dogs smell the world so much
better than we do and how can we train
them to detect something as invisible
and intangible as disease
smell is the oldest of all the senses or
at least a rudimentary version of it is
before sight hearing or even touch
organisms evolved to respond to the
chemicals around them
even the most simple of bacteria can
follow a chemical scent trail
and with hundreds of millions of years
of evolution behind it it's no surprise
that smell is a sense that in some
animals has evolved to be fantastically
complex
but what actually is a smell
a smell or odor is a volatile molecule
one that has shed from its source and
then wasps through the air or even
travels through the water until it's
picked up by an animal
for most animals this begins with a
sniff
a sniff for us is a rather clumsy affair
we breathe some air into our nostril
holes and then out the same holes over
and over trying to make sense of the
odor we've detected
but a dog's sniff is much more complex
it begins with muscles in the nostrils
drawing a current of air and any scent
chemicals into them
then on the exhale instead of going
straight back out the air exits through
slits in the sides of the nose and
backwards
in this way inhaled odors don't get
mixed with the air already in the nose
allowing each new inhale to be pure and
undiluted
and on top of this the direction of the
exhaled air does more than just get out
of the way of new air
it actually helps to pull more of the
new scent in by creating a current of
air that pulls the odor from the object
being scented towards the nose
when a dog is investigating a scent it
repeats this inspiration expiration
cycle very quickly about five times per
second
from here the scent travels up the dog's
nasal passage into the nasal turbinates
this is a labyrinth of bony ridges that
are covered with mucous membranes which
provides a large surface area for the
air breathed in to be warmed and cleaned
before entering the ethmoid turbinates
here is where the dog's super ability
begins to shine
lining the ethmoid turbinates is the
olfactory epithelium the membrane which
contains millions of scent receptors the
olfactory receptor neurons each covered
in cilia
the neurons are activated when ascent
binds to the olfactory receptors on the
cilia
some of these receptors are shaped to
pair with only a few select molecules in
a hyperspecific lock and key fashion
but most olfactory receptors will bind
to a large number of different molecules
the brain can decipher specific smells
based on the combinations of receptors
that are activated and the sheer number
of these olfactory receptor neurons and
their cilia in dogs is part of what
gives dogs their super ability
we have around 6 million olfactory
receptor neurons each with about 25
cilia dogs have as many as 300 million
olfactory receptor neurons each with
hundreds of cilia
dogs have more genes dedicated to
creating olfactory cells more cells and
more types of cells and when these
things work in unison when combinations
of sites fire together to send
information to the brain
dogs can detect significantly more types
of smells and in smaller concentrations
once the scent is picked up by the
neuron a signal is sent to the olfactory
bulb the olfactory bulb is a bulb of
neural tissue within the dog's brain and
is responsible for processing smells
it's approximately 40 times larger in
dogs than in humans relative to total
brain size
from the olfactory bulb the sense
information then travels to the cortex
where it's finally recognized as a smell
to the dog this part of a dog's sense of
smell is enough to outperform us to an
extraordinary degree
but on top of all of this dogs have a
second way to smell the world an entire
olfactory ability that we don't even
have in the roof of a dog's mouth is the
vomeronasal organ an organ that picks up
pheromones
pheromones are talked about a lot but
what they actually are is kind of crazy
their chemicals an animal produces that
act much like hormones do except for
that they act outside of the body
affecting the behavior of other animals
dogs will purposely leave pheromones
behind in their urine to tell other dogs
about their gender and sexual
receptivity and the closer the sniffing
dog can get to these chemicals the
better
other animals have this organ too when
you see a lizard darting its tongue out
to touch an object it's not tasting it
or smelling it it's sampling chemicals
and bringing them closer to the
vomeronasal organ
it's deeply contested whether or not
humans have this organ
but even if we do have some version of
it our pheromone detecting abilities are
basically non-existent compared to a
dog's
hounds in particular are a type of dog
with one of the strongest senses of
smell
not only do they have the highest number
of olfactory receptors in their noses
but other features of their body also
enable them to smell extra strongly
their ears are ridiculously long not to
hear better but to waft more scented air
up towards their nose
basset hounds even have short legs to
keep their head close to the ground at
scent level and their seemingly constant
drooling helps bring extra liquids up to
the vomeronasal organ
naturally these dogs have an incredible
sense of smell but with some training
what they can do is incredible
in one study researchers took five clean
glass slides and added a single
fingerprint to one of them
the slides were then put away for up to
three weeks when presented with the
slides again one dog was able to detect
the slide touched by a human correctly
99 out of a hundred trials
when the five slides were then placed
outside for a week exposed to sun rain
wind and debris the dog was still able
to select the correct slide over 50 of
the time
a trained dog can even smell a cadaver
under cement at least 15 feet or 4.5
meters down
or on a lighter note they can stand at
the front of a boat and sniff the water
to help researchers locate whales since
dogs can smell whale poop from over a
mile away
and incredibly dogs don't just notice
smells they notice very small changes in
those smells
in one study a human participant walked
in a straight line on a trail
a dog was then brought in
perpendicularly to that trail
the dog could of course smell that
someone had recently walked by but they
could also smell the direction the
person was traveling in as few as five
steps this is because the dog can sense
the change and smell over time in this
way a dog can reconstruct the path taken
and dogs can smell things even more
intangible than steps
they've been shown to be the earliest
most accurate disease detectors that
researchers have ever seen
even better than the best current lab
tests
when looking for cancer in a human
patient doctors can test for a lot of
different things in the body that
indicate cancer might be present
things like tumor markers such as
calcitonin for thyroid cancer or
prostate-specific antigen for prostate
cancer immunoglobulins circulating the
blood when cancer is present and even
tumor cells themselves or their genetic
material circulating the body
these tests can help detect some cancers
early but certain cancers like lung
cancer don't show up in its early stages
in any of these tests in fact there's
not a single blood test available that
can accurately detect lung cancer
it's usually only found once it's spread
wildly throughout the body
which is a huge contributing reason that
lung cancer is the most common type of
cancer death in the western world
so researchers put a sniffer dog to the
test to see if it could detect some
indicator of lung cancer that we can't
the experiment began when a golden
retriever was conditioned through
classical conditioning the dog was
presented with lung cancer samples and
control samples and a correct indication
of a lung cancer sample was rewarded
with food
this process took around one year
then 42 lung cancer patients with tumors
in various stages
along with healthy controls provided
urine and breath samples
and with a combination of these samples
the dog correctly detected 40 out of 41
cancer samples a success rate of 97.6
for a cancer that can normally only be
detected with a ct scan this is
incredible
other studies have found that dogs can
also detect other cancers with similar
accuracy such as bladder or breast
cancer
along with other diseases like diabetes
covid19 malaria and parkinson's disease
and every once in a while during one of
these studies something strange happens
sometimes a dog will keep misidentifying
a member of the control group as being
positive for the disease
even though that person had been
selected specifically because a hospital
test confirmed them to be disease free
researchers marked these as false
positives
this kept happening for one patient in a
bladder cancer study so the person
decided to have more testing done
and sure enough a few months later a
hospital test found the disease at a
very early stage
disease detecting dogs are now being
used to provide early screening for
firefighters in california who are at
high risk of developing cancer due to
the toxins they're exposed to in their
line of work and once the fda figures
out how to regulate animal-based
diagnostics this could be a part of
regular healthcare for everyone
so when the dogs detect cancer what
compound are they actually smelling the
answer is we don't exactly know
a person's breath in a test tube or
urine in a cup contains millions of
volatile organic compounds
we've never been able to distill
ourselves which compounds or combination
of compounds a dog is picking up on when
it detects a disease
however researchers at mit are working
to recreate a dog's sniffing abilities
in an automated odor detection system
they designed a machine that mimics
mammalian olfactory receptors that act
as sensors
the problem is even if the machine can
detect many different chemical
signatures
researchers are still unable to parse
this data which combination of thousands
out of millions of compounds indicate
cancer
this is where machine learning comes in
by applying a machine learning program
researchers could tease out any
similarities and differences between
disease samples that can help the system
identify the disease
and when tested with confirmed cases of
prostate cancer along with disease-free
controls the artificial system was able
to match the success rates of dogs with
both methods scoring more than 70
percent
researchers hope that one day such smell
detecting bots will be available to
everyone maybe even built into your
smartphone
however the combination of compounds
that smell like cancer remains a secret
known only to the dogs and the robots
so when you tell your dog to get a job
as i often do you might have a point
there are many dogs out there actually
saving lives
my dog is very notably unemployed
her nine to five activity is sleeping in
a bean bag next to me while i work
but i still wonder how much she can
really pick up on
she isn't trained to detect disease but
can she smell my emotions
can she sense differences in my body
can she smell when i'm happy
stressed agitated how i lose 100 brain
cells every time i turn on the news or
read something about donald trump on
reddit this i don't know but i do know
that the news cycle and the overall
state of this country is distracting i
do my best to tune it out but inevitably
i get sucked back in through social
media
it's a tricky balance between staying
informed and ending up doom-scrolling
and wasting time while also feeling like
crap
so i recently decided to get my news in
a different way with morningbrew a daily
newsletter delivered to my inbox every
morning that gets me up to speed on
business finance tech and politics in
just five minutes
it's both witty and concise and gives me
the gist of all the important headlines
without the fluff and sensationalism
morning brew can't make the news better
but it can make it understandable and
digestible and the best part about it is
it's completely free if you've ever
thought about supporting this channel
here is your easiest chance all it takes
is 15 seconds and an email address
signing up is the best way to support us
so thank you to anyone who has so to get
a new and improved morning news routine
click the link in the description to get
started with morning brew today and if
you're looking for something else to
watch right now you can watch our most
recent video about the insane biology of
the electric eel
or you can watch real engineering's
latest video about a fascinating attempt
to fling a satellite into space
[Music]
you